so here's another triangle and just like
before I don't know whether it's right
angled or not what I'm gonna show you
now is sort of a faster way of doing
things maybe you're like I don't want to
label everything it takes me a while to
be fair if you do the working I'm about
to show you it's pretty clear what's
going on but you still need to be very
cautious in the way you set out you're
working okay
I'm not going to label any other size
I'm trying to do this slightly faster so
I'm going to go straight to talking
about the squares of the two shorter
science which ones are those which are
the shorter numbers yeah go ahead
8 and 15 you can just see them in order
right so I'm going to say 8 squared plus
15 squared and I'm gonna work out what
it is okay
hey it's squared can we do it it's good
now heads 64 thank you
can we do 15 squared you know has Mary
yeah oh so close it is two hundred and
something in five it's here two three
five now made me feel like I wasn't sure
wait do we do we do have calculators for
this right this is why they are there
and for numbers like this it starts to
starts to get a bit big but to be honest
you're going to see 15 squared a whole
lot so maybe get used to calculating it
and working it out 64 plus 225 mmm do we
need to write this vertical you reckon
we can handle it
yeah I don't know 200 and the tens add
up to 8 the units add up to 9 and I gave
you nice numbers and you didn't have to
carry ones or anything okay so there we
go
that's the sum of the squares of the
shorter sides we're gonna have a look at
the longest side now that's 16 squared
okay hmm this one is less common but if
you're a computer nerd like me you know
numbers like this because they're powers
of 2 16 squared does anyone know what 16
times 16 is yeah ah
is it 289 now here's an interesting
thing right even if you don't know
exactly what 16 times 16 is there's a
way you can quickly tell sadly for us in
this triangle it's not gonna be 289 that
last digit there that units digit right
how can you get 9 well you could have
like 3 times 3 that would be 9
you could have 9 times 1 I guess those
are your only 2
factors right but here I've got two
sixes will happen what six times six
it's 36 right so the only unit you're
gonna get out of this is a six that's in
fact the last digit does anyone know
what the rest of the digits are yeah
very good
20:56 and by the way you can see it is
just a bit bigger than this one this is
15 squared this is the next one 16
square just a little bit bigger okay now
what's happened here my age squared of
my B squared when I add them together
they do not match with my C squared do
this so I can write this a squared plus
sorry 8 squared plus 15 squared is not
equal to 16 square right they don't line
up a squared plus B squared aren't equal
to 16 squared therefore and those three
dots indicate okay I'm gonna make a
logical step from here the triangle
isn't right angle that's a bit sad but
that's okay
by the way 289 it actually happens to be
a square number does anyone know what
it's the square of yeah it's the next
one 17 squared so we've got 5 12 13 here
that's a Pythagorean triad 8 15 17 is
another piping where you try as some of
you might've actually already identified
that by doing your homework say we had
asked you to find a few but this one's a
bit of an imposter it's just a little
bit off okay now what we've used over
here on the right hand side you might
have noticed is neither Pythagoras's
theorem nor its converse it's actually
something different it's the opposite
right it's when the triangle isn't right
angled and that's why you've got in your
little table there you've got a right
hand side over there right so you can
see there's Pythagoras theorem and on
the Left you've got the original version
a square plus B squared equals C cleared
underneath you've got your converse that
looks like this let me show you how I
would put the right-hand side of the
table and I apologize it looks a bit
cheesy but it'll work I'm gonna do this
first so you can actually read it
stay there we go okay
we make a tea bit smaller for you think
oh so can you see what I've got here and
what it means right if you know that
you're trying was right angle you can
say you can conclude you've got this s
squared plus B squared equals C squared
thing that's really nice
right if on the other hand like our five
twelve thirteen triangle over here if
you test out the sides even if you don't
know whether it's right angled or not
even if the question doesn't tell you if
this works out you can say oh yeah it
must be right-angled but what do we do
just now with our eight fifteen sixteen
triangle which one did we use can you
see it wasn't either of these two
because these are where everything is
nice and it works out which one is yeah
sure yeah it's this bottom right hand
corner right we checked out a squared
plus B squared then we checked out C
squared and we're like oh they're not
equal to each other right and that means
no no this can't possibly be a
right-angled triangle okay so that's why
I've got a red line through it
okay um you've got this too by the way
which we didn't really deal with and
doesn't come up very frequently but I
look at this and I'm kind of like oh
it's missing a cell this is to make a
complete if you got a triangle it's not
right angled then you can actually say
Pythagoras theorem will not work out but
you weren't thinking about anyway
because we use Pythagoras when it is
right angle okay all right so I'm going
to leave this up here for a minute
because I'd love you to UM I didn't want
to print it in color because that would
be a horrendous waste of color toner but
you might have some colors on you and
you can probably draw it in a more vivid
way if you've got them at your table and
I'm also going to put this up on canvas
too so that you have a reference to it
but it's for me I had a friend at school
and he made really cool notes on all of
this subjects English and history and
that kind of thing and he was really
generous who share his notes with me but
I never did as well in my exams than he
did and the reason why is because the
value of notes is not in reading them
the value of notes is in making them if
you construct them yourselves that's
where you actually start to put things
to sink into your brain okay
all right so I'll leave that up for
another brief moment I will put it back
if some of you are like no wait I
haven't finished yet but does anyone
have any questions about that so far hmm
okay now I've one last all you started
you do have a question yeah go ahead
are you asking or sure if I write this
sort of the other way around yeah in a
manner of speaking it's still called
Pythagoras theorem and the real reason
why that is is because yeah this equals
sign right the reason why by the way an
equal sign is an equal sign is because
it's literally two objects that are
identical did you notice that some of
the symbols are exactly what they what
they look like right like the division
sign have you ever thought about the
division sign if you've got two things
and then you want to divide them up then
you just sort of separate them that ah
that's what the division sign means same
deal with the equal sign now if they are
two things that are truly identical then
it kind of doesn't matter which one you
say is which so you could actually just
interchange them and it'd still be
Pythagoras's theorem okay